it should be the most secure place in
kabul
the green zone in afghanistan's capital
but that didn't prevent an attack
apparently aimed at the country's
defence minister
explosions and small arms far as it
seems gunmen were able to penetrate the
area
the fighting that's sweeping through
afghanistan after the withdrawal of
allied forces
now reaching the heart of the country's
capital
then sometime later while fires from the
blast still burned
kabul residents out in protest against
the attacks
chanting god is great in defiance of the
taliban
and supporting their government and
armed forces
[Applause]
the same chant but from the other side
in the southern city of lashkar
this week as taliban fighters entered
parts of the city
[Music]
if it falls or the other is also under
assault the afghan government
will be in deepening trouble
but the most immediate fear is of an
impending humanitarian disaster
tens of thousands of people are on the
move terrified of the taliban
and the upsurge in fighting one former
u.n official told sky news the situation
is deeply worrying
and needs urgent international action it
is an extremely large number
much much larger than um totally
acceptable and i think the international
community needs to step up
its commitment to aid and i really
stress
that the international community has to
speak out
uh with unequivocal voice together
and this is very important that they
speak out together at the highest levels
now unexpected peace and calm after the
allied withdrawal
but few anticipated the taliban's
advances to be so swift
[Music]
and now an attack in the capitals green
zone likely to demoralize government
forces
and cast further doubt on their ability
to keep afghans safe
with the fate of several key cities now
hanging in the balance
the next few weeks could determine the
future of the country
and its increasingly beleaguered
government
dominic waghorn sky news